daily wires been Shapira been we're
always talking to when the left is in
him unhinged and you have a special way
of unhinging them but this was really I
mean I keep saying a new low but this
really is a new low I've never heard of
this person before but I guess he's kind
of big in the tech world where are we
here I mean I've been called worse by
better so you know that that's just the
way things go I guess these days yeah I
guess that he works or said that he
worked over at Vox and then it turns out
that he was not in fact a co-founder of
Vox if he was from box and Vox is not
sending its best that's all I can really
say about it but we have we have a an
individual who works for this tech
website saying that someone who is an
observant Jew is helping put other Jews
on the train meaning I guess the Trump
train can't you know ever look past that
but the you know he's obviously I think
he's Jewish as well but coming from from
him who I believe is Jewish is that have
any special significance to you is it
kind of a self-loathing deal what is it
I mean not particularly I mean I assume
he's calling me a Nazi but he wouldn't
be the only one the way that the left
works these days than anyone who
disagrees with them as a Nazi so it
really isn't giant surprised I always
find it ironic when the left attacks me
as in all right Nazi considering I was
literally the number one recipient of
all tried hatred in 2016 according to
the anti-defamation league which is not
a right-wing source right and then there
are others on the left who have gone
from there never Trump mania to just you
know completely out of touch with the
reality of politics today one of them is
a I guess a blogger for the Washington
Post who's on television quite a bit her
name is Jennifer Rubin let's watch
Huckabee has no right to live a life of
no fuss no muss after lying to the press
after inciting against the press these
people should be made uncomfortable and
I think that's a life sentence frankly
you should be made uncomfortable for
life it should be a life sentence do you
notice that the the words that the left
and the never Trump I don't know
Republican or Bush
whoosh bird I have no idea how you
describe Jennifer Rubin because there's
literally no constituency other than
like Bill Kristol for what she says but
they've now used this criminal imagery
there
Trump is jailing babies they're
criminalizing Parenthood with the
separation of families you know the
concentration camps although the the
tension centers are concentration camps
it's all it's it's beyond descriptive
it's descriptive in this criminal
over-the-top purposely outrageous manner
what of that now coming from you know I
guess a former Republican yeah I mean
she's obviously engaged in in the
endorsement of thug tactics and then
this is the desperation to which the
left and some people formerly of the
right have been driven I mean Jen Rubin
is a person who not only endorsed Mitt
Romney and pushed very hard from this
MIT Romney just a few years ago she was
suggesting that roe v-- wade needed to
be overturned now she says that any
judge who's appointed to the Supreme
Court by President Trump cannot want to
overturn roe v wade there there's a
certain derangement obviously that's
said in with a lot of people where they
have reversed principles that they
supposedly once held specifically
because they don't like Donald Trump
which I find not only puzzling but
morally vacuous and when you look at Jen
Rubin saying stuff like Sarah Huckabee
Sanders should be made uncomfortable for
life and she doesn't have a right to be
comfortable in the United States well
she does have a right to to basically
not be mopped when she goes out to a gas
station or when she goes out to eat
dinner the same people who are saying
bake the cake to religious bakers are
saying that it's what people have left
have even gone further than that I mean
they're talking about not just
restaurant owners saying they don't want
Trump employees in their establishments
they're talking about how it's now okay
for mobs to descend on other people's
establishments and drive people out of
those establishments right that's what
happened to Christian Nielsen so the the
level of insanity to which the left
evolves every day is a testament to how
much President Trump is in their heads
and in a testament to how their utopian
idealism under President Obama has
absolutely collapsed and then the
farther left they go the higher his
numbers seem to go so they don't see the
correlation but perhaps they'll be you
know saner Minds will prevail ultimately
Ben have a happy Independence Day thanks
so much for being with us tonight